j'accueille maintenant henri emmanuelli
henry lui bonsoir vous blesser
dieffenthal kad et olivier françoise
hardy daniel prévost alors henri
emmanuelli dans le débat sur les stock
options plus que les verts ou
chevènement c'est vous qui avez tenu
laurent fabius en échec non j'ai pas
tenu des chèques
j'ai défendu klaus barbie très en votre
faveur et puis après on fait des
compromis c'est la vie c'est comme dans
la vie de couple faisait bienvenus vous
pouvez d'ailleurs si fabius se remplace
un peu au gouvernement dominique strauss
kahn vous vous remplacer un petit peu
martine aubry qui va briguer la mairie
de lille s'est elle a du charme je suis
très flatté parce que vous êtes un peu
le contrepoint c'était un peu le
contrepoids à fabius maintenant comme
aubry il l'était à strauss kahn
il ya des rôles comme ça dans la vie
daniel prévost il fut le seul méchant
quoi voilà tout à l'heure il faisait le
psychanalyste et moi je ne mets jamais
vous vous êtes le mec qui a des
convictions et qui les fait respecté ce
pas mal comme mon rôle je vais vous dire
moi je trouve pas ça très polie de dire
le mec s'est pas dit non j'ai trouvé
dans le vieux monsieur le mec submarine
est aussi monsieur lemay le mec bien en
tous les cas tout va bien pour vous mais
au remaniement vous avez été un petit
peu oublié écoutez je venais d'arriver
mais pas tout à l'heure le grand oublié
du du remaniement ça c'est pas mal ça
donc vous avez fait rire comme ça il
sourit tout le temps
vous avez été réélu brillamment des ptt
un réel brio les landais président de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale
et puis c'est un peu une revanche
finalement sur ce que vous avez subi à
l'époque de la sphère urba vous avez été
inculpé pour complicité de trafic
d'influencé
deux ans d'inégibilité j'ai un peu payé
pour les autres humains de son boulot
non c'est jeudi pas à plaindre puis ça
m'a donné l'occasion de faire des choses
mais on en parle et deux ans
d'inéligibilité bon en même temps elle a
un peu payé pour les autres parce que
c'est vrai que on s'est attaqué à un
homme plutôt qu'à une institution vous
étiez trésorier du ps c'est pour ça que
je vais payer pour les autres quoi là je
vous laisse faire les commentaires parce
que moi j'avais tellement fait ouais
puis c'est tellement envie de parler
d'autres ou non on va parler d'autre
chose mais c'est important quand même
nom s'est sacrifié pour le parti c'est
bien j'aime pas le mot sacrifiée il ya
eu un contexte et puis que j'étais là je
passais par là et les moments faut pas
passer par la cua ouais enfin quand même
ça force l'admiration tout le monde le
dit là il n'a pas balancé qui déclare
monsieur le mec pardon il n'a pas
balancé tu vas ramé a pas du tout amélie
je vois très bien vous êtes n'est pas
trop pour la nouvelle économie vous vous
êtes vous dit on est un peu le nez dans
la marijuana boursière oui je suis pas
ce que ça veut dire la nouvelle économie
il ya des gens qui produisent il ya des
gens qui vendent il ya des gens qui
achètent il ya des échanges et celle
impression ça ça n'a pas beaucoup changé
quoi alors vas pas la même chose
heureusement ni les mêmes choses mais je
crois que ça fait partie des effets de
mode mais ça passera pas à tous les cas
pour vous ce qu'on peut dire pour vous
des filles pour finir de vous définir le
social n'est pas un sous produit de
l'économie non je crois pas voilà donc
on pourrait dire que fabius c'est la
modernisation et vous vous êtes un peu
la redistribution à tout cas moi je suis
très attaché à la redistribution c'est
pour ça que je suis en résidence partie
si ça devait plus être le cas ça
poserait quelques problèmes comme si les
socialistes ne pipa qui s'en occupera
reproche suffisamment de passage
occupaient l'année quelqu'un qui
persévèrent quand on me dit que cette
archaïque ça vous énerve
au début ça m'énervait puis alors
maintenant ça me laisse de glace parce
que ce genre de généralités
tahar cailly qui est ceci et cela c'est
comme quand on dit daniel prévost il est
bon ça lui fait plus rien il le sait oui
c'est vrai voilà la raison me suis
évanoui
est ce que votre vie à un homme de goût
tu vois il me signe dans son discours
c'est pas oublier l'inspecteur des
impôts way
personne n'a oublié est ce que votre
vieux différend avec laurent fabius
viendrait pas de vos origines c'est pas
de la même classe sociale n'est pas non
écoutez je crois que on a eu des
différends de politique mais j'ai moi
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour laurent
fabius que je respecte que j'ai appris
d'ailleurs vous connaissez plus
longtemps oui depuis plus de vingt ans
donc je les aime bien mais non je veux
pas trop en rajouter non plus parce
qu'on va dire il en fait trop ouais et
lui-même savall surprendre il va parler
des questions mais bon moi j'ai pas
d'animosité jeu plutôt du respect pour
lui mais comment faire quand je parle
par exemple de deux classes sociales
nouveaux parents c'était vraiment des
croyants communiste pour le communisme
c'est une espèce de religion votre père
était militant cgt et c'était viré pour
ça d'ailleurs
il est devenu artisan électricien et il
est mort en réparant à vignes quoi sur
un clocher en clocher ça c'est terrible
ça pas aux militants
oui surtout pour vous qui êtes un
bouffeur de curé quand même s'il dit
seigneur alors et c'est complet le père
d'emmanuelli bouffeurs de curé est mort
en réparant à cocher oui et d'ailleurs
en 78 a déclaré à l'assemblée nationale
à bâle hakan admirer ces bouffeurs de
curés y avait une histoire
il y avait une discussion qui n'en
finissait pas et j'avais déclaré que je
venais d'arriver
j'étais tout jeune ouais c'est pas qu'on
mène donc ouais maintenant vous gériez
plus à bas la calotte
non parce que je pense que plus sujet
est ce que changer je peux le sujet une
étable à la culotte
oui alors il magnifie parce que vous
avez fait baptiser vos enfants les deux
oui oui parce que meeke et bouffeurs de
curés c'est bizarre quand même mais
parce que moi je sais que je considère
qu'ils doivent être en situation dans
une cité dans une civilisation
judéo-chrétienne mon frère n'avait pas
fait et sa fille ensuite lui a reproché
alors elle a fait une fixation sur le
fait qu était pas baptisé dont j'ai dit
les miens ne font pas de fixation voilà
la mère d'henri emmanuelli on a été
surnommé 14 juillet donc je sais quand
même
ce qui était plutôt dix députés et ta
soeur et j'en ai pour cette famille
absolument
vous êtes un mec courageux parce qu'en
63 vous débarquez à paris à sciences po
et vous repartez trois ans dans le béarn
quand votre mère est malade vous
repartez trois ans pour vous occuper
d'elle lors de vie votre carrière à
faire et si à paris et vous repartez ça
c'est la vie on n'a pas toujours le
choix on s'occupe des siens c'est le
minimum 1 c'est bien il me semble on se
croit pas que ce soit un exploit quand
vous revenez donc à paris après vous
rentrez dans une banque airlines a des
points communs avec regus bizarrement
parce que vous avez ça en commun c'est à
dire que vous en 72 assez incroyable
aussi c'est comme le fait d'avoir fait
baptiser vos enfants en 72 vous entrez
chez rothschild henri emmanuelli chez
rothschild à la banque rothschild
oui c'est énorme quand on croyable bah
oui on savait pas en vérité justice et
découvrait quelque chose de terrible je
suis d'abord entré dans une banque qui
s'appelait le manque de l'union
parisienne teambank protestante banque
d'affaires et ensuite je suis allé chez
à la compagnie financière chez le moment
autres chine c'est insensé a pas du tout
j'étais très bien
ce sont deux ans plus tard j'ai rentré
dans une charcuterie d'ailleurs à peu
près sur la même manière comme pompidou
quand même
pompidou il a bossé chez rothschild cie
l'ofce le coucher vote si vous souhaitez
adresser c'est commode parce qu'il ya
des gens qui ont envoyé des lettres
quand je militais 1 à la banque
rothschild abrutis dimon connaît pas
celui-là
1 oui ça m'a sauvé ça m'a aidé alors
finalement henri emmanuelli quand le
wall street journal dit on peut toujours
compter sur les socialistes pour nous
faire rire quand il parle d'économie
vous vous fait rire parce que vous la
connaissez l'économie vous avez bossé
chez oui bon ça fait partie des
généralités des préjugés
et je pense qu'un aussi grand journal
devrait avoir un peu plus de finesse
dans l'analyse quoi mais bon c'est pas
grave hein une forme leur point de vue
ils sont là pour ça faut bien qu'il vaut
mieux gagner leur vie et vit des moments
marrant quand vous étiez dans la banque
c'est des mecs qui venait bouffer dans
la salle à manger de la banque et qui
disait ici au moins on peut parler c'est
pas comme dans les banques nationalisées
qui sont truffés de socialisme était ce
là je me souvienne de sa wii oui j'ai
même organisé à l'époque quelques rendez
vous entre des responsables du parti et
puis des gens
bon c'était dans une banque on n'était
pas armé c'est faire ce que je voulais
quand même
parallèlement à ces impacts quand la
conversation serait aussi sérieuse moi
mais ça dépend c'est ce qui fait le
charme de cette émission c'est qu'on
peut dire des grosses conneries depuis
30 ans moi oui si vous une bonne comme
la plus chargée est passé parce que ces
empreintes sont plombées depuis qu'henri
est arrivé en même temps ouais non
mairie était parée pour rigoler mais il
est arrivé mais il a parlé de son père
sur le clocher penché sur le pilote ou
en même temps vous êtes chez rothschild
vous rencontrer françois mitterrand la
même année à peu près quelques bouts de
chou vous progressez dans ma vie aurait
été différent allez paris
un peu plus là et extrêmement courtois
et bien élevé mais là il peut plus il
n'y a plus rien pourquoi la tiens était
en forme c'est vrai que toi non bien pas
preuve continue avec monsieur emmanuelli
oui je traite que j'aimais vraiment j'ai
honte je les traits je les appelais
henry je le connais pas du tout la
préface leur encontre
mais si elle savait mais moi je vous
connais moi c'est tout à fait gentil moi
je connais moi je vous adhériez on va
donc effectivement vous montez au parti
socialiste
à l'époque vous vous êtes inculpés dans
cette affaire
urbas la sphère des strates pourquoi les
gens du parti vous ont pas soutenu vont
laisser un petit peu ils sont pas levés
comme un seul homme on peut dire quoi
bon on peut pas donc on peut pas dire ça
comme ça non plus je croyais jeu ils ont
fait ce qu'ils avaient à faire et ce
qu'ils croyaient devoir faire n'hésitez
pas des circontances facile vous leur en
voulais pas mais non écoutez les
socialistes ils sont comme ils sont
humains il appartient au genre humain
donc ils ont les qualités et les défauts
vous savez ce que c'est ce n'est pas une
race à part vous a été vraiment déprimé
à l'époque vous allez non non vraiment
pas non non c'était dur mais dix prix
mais non je je je déprime pas facilement
justement alors on en arrive à votre
livre si tu avais interdit de chez
ramsay zoom zoom mon garçon
dieffenthal baehler diefenthal je ne
crois pas j'y passe
bravo france
j'accuse 6%
c'était vraiment c'est ce qu'elle menait
dans toutes les missions ce bouquin
c'est pas c'est pas un tract politique
vous avez faire dire de bouquins
politique sur l'europe ya quelques
années c'est pas une biographie de dôme
historique de personnages historiques
comme font tous les tous les hommes
politiques qui font tout ça sarkozy a
fait mandel bées roux a fait henri iv
séguin napoléon iii c'est pas ça du tout
c'est un roman mais là où c'est un tout
petit peu autobiographique quand même
c'est un homme foudroyé par un drame
personnel et qui est pris au piège de
l'appareil judiciaire parce qu'il
fallait que je trouve une situation un
peu paroxystique pour aller au bout de
certaines réflexions et donc supporter
jusqu au passage je pourrais faire d'une
pierre deux coups mais ce n'était pas
l'objectif
en réalité bon dans le livre est un
homme qui quitte sa vie parce qu'il
s'est toujours un peu son petit décalé à
l'écart il veut savoir pourquoi
à eelv à un certain moment il sort
pourquoi et à ce moment là
retournant chez un demi frère il est
pris dans un imbroglio où il est pris
dans une halle ce soir d'un homme qui
lui qui fit part et après le décès de sa
femme enceinte et une musicienne dans un
accident il se réfugie dans les pyrénées
gers en 2000 frère cadet et là il est
mêlé à une affaire c'est sale affaire de
terroristes basques
il ya un policier des rg qui tue est
donc celle allons l'engrenage voilà qui
va conduire des gens en prison en
préventive et pour moi c'était
l'occasion cette prison était évidemment
l'endroit où on réfléchit avec un peu
plus d'épaisseur et des densités que
dans la vie normale mais pour moi le
sujet du livre c'était ça c'était la
réflexion du bonhomme c'est pas c'est
pas la justice la justice j'en parle
mais pour dire grosso modo que la
société actuelle lui à lui assigne un
rôle difficile qui est un petit peu
situé entre le sacré et ce qui ne l'est
pas c'est à dire la responsabilité de
dire le bien et le mal ce qui est une
responsabilité énorme et qu' elle le
fait parce que la société lui assigne ce
rôle et ce qui est paradoxal d'ailleurs
c'est qu'on lui aussi une ce rôle et
qu'en même temps lui reproche de le
tenir
donc je vous crois que je traite j'avais
quand vous n'êtes pas attendre aussi
pour la pour la presse si c'est un
graphique page 145 vous dit
la presse a fait le maximum pour noircir
le tableau comme vous aviez dit dans un
journal des journalistes sont les
pigistes des juges sur les journalistes
suscitait frapper parce qu'on fait la
remarque en fait je dis rien
d'extraordinaire je je je dis simplement
le bonhomme qui découvre les médias et
qui s'aperçoit que cette affaire qui
croyait privée devient public à ce
moment là ils vont se dérouler un
feuilleton sous ses yeux
mais c'est ce qui arrive tous les jours
à tous ceux qui sont pris sous les feux
de l'actualité pour pour quelle que soit
la raison d'ailleurs je pense qu'ils ont
peu près tous la même réaction me
semble-t-il vite le plus terrible dans
l'innocence bafouée que ça aussi c'est
quelque chose que vous êtes arrivé c'est
qu'on finit par se sentir coupable je
pense effectivement que tous ceux qui
ont regardé de près comment se passer
certaines situations y compris les plus
tragiques dans le choix ont tous dit
qu'à un moment donné les gens qu'on met
en situation de culpabilité finissent
par se sentir un peu coupable
tout simplement parce qu'il faut qu'il
trouve une raison à cette situation là
et qu'ils ont le choix entre se sentir
un peu coupable ou bien l'absurdité la
gratuité alors petit à petit bascule
dans ces syndromes stockholm c'est à
dire que la voilà la victime finit par
l'herbe
voila voila et le je crois plutôt les
bourreaux connaissent ce genre de
perversion et c'est là c'est ce que je
fais 10 ans sert sancerre voilà bien ça
s'appelle citadelle interdite sécher
rams et c'est henri emmanuelli
henri emmanuelli maintenant la mer
exercice un petit peu compliqué souvent
les hommes politiques car il mieux que
les autres sais pas pourquoi